un ataque con drones en el crimen ha
sucedido en plena noche lo ha revelado
el propio gabinete del presidente ruso
que ha avisado a Ucrania de que la parte
rusa Se reserva a partir de ahora el
derecho a responder Dónde y cuándo lo
considere conveniente hay que recordar
que justo el presidente ucraniano al
cual Rusia acusa de estos ataques no se
encuentra ni siquiera en Ucrania sino
precisamente de viaje en Finlandia el
ataque se produjo durante la noche pero
no se ha conocido hasta bien entrado el
día aquí en
Moscú hay imágenes de distintos canales
de Telegram de vecinos pero desde la
oficina del presidente se ha avisado de
que Putin por supuesto no estaba en ese
momento en el kremel De hecho hace años
que Putin no vive allí sino que vive
pernocta y ahora también trabaja también
desde hace años en el Palacio
Residencial de novo garego que está
situado A las afueras de Moscú el crimen
avisa que el presidente ruso no va a
cambiar su agenda por este ataque